it took the jury five full days more
than 40 hours of deliberations elaine
maxwell guilty on five of the six
charges she faced convicted of grooming
young girls for sexual abuse by her
former boyfriend jeffrey epstein and
even sometimes joining in
the british socialite remained calm and
whispered to her lawyer and drank a sip
of water as the verdicts were read out
outside court maxwell's friend lee
saffian a regular throughout the trial
left without comment a chance to give a
reaction to the verdict
for the prosecution the verdict was a
welcome relief the road to justice has
been far too long
but today
justice has been done
i want to commend the bravery of the
girls now grown women who stepped out of
the shadows and into the courtroom
their courage and willingness to face
their abuser made today's result in this
case possible
the trial attracted enormous global
attention wealthy and influential
epstein and maxwell moved in elite
circles counting the rich and famous
even former presidents and britain's
prince andrew among their friends and
associates
maxwell's lawyers argued that she'd
become a scapegoat for epstein's crimes
he committed suicide while awaiting
trial in august 2019
defense lawyers attempted to poke holes
in the testimony of the four main
witnesses
and even brought in memory experts to
undermine their accounts
but to no avail
we firmly believe in glenn's innocence
obviously we are very disappointed with
the verdict
we have already started working on the
appeal and we are confident that she
will be vindicated elaine maxwell turned
60 years old during these jury
deliberations
the sentencing will be at a later date
but she's now facing up to 65 years in
prison
gabrielle zondo al jazeera new york